welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka The Fresh
Prince of spoilers but that was bad
and it's time to break down bad boys for
life throughout this video we'll be
going through the movies final a few
scenes and giving our thoughts and where
it could all be going and the film as a
whole the movie is a hell of a fun ride
and it has a great mid-credits scene
that has a lot to unpack from it it sets
up a big sequel coming down the line and
we may be getting bad boys for a lot
sooner than you think
now obviously there's gonna be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't seen the
movie yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now without the way I just
wouldn't give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of bad boys for life
bad boys for life once more centers
around Marcus Burnett in Mike Lowrey the
film opens with the former telling the
latter that he wishes to retire in the
wake of his grandson being born because
Marcus is too old for this ish
throughout the movie it's sort of jumps
back and forth between whether he's
gonna retire or not and I loved seeing
the ones exuberant Martin Lawrence
dealing with the fact that he may not be
a spring chicken anymore as we get older
it's something we all have to deal with
and his performance against the ever
youthful looking Smith is really well
portrayed I feel bad that he has to try
and keep up with Smith but yeah he's
still there's a great job early on it
looks like everyone could be getting a
happy ending
but things take a big turn when Mike is
shot several times by an assassin named
Armando is it a mono
or Amanda it says a mondo and IMD fella
I don't know anyway this kick starts the
movie with Mike trying to take down the
assassin whilst also learning some home
truths a mando is completely cut
throughout and he takes out high-ranking
members of the authorities which really
shows that he's a danger Joe Pantoliano
gets whacked which is a big moment and
the movie also brings back some
characters such as Reggie as Michael Bay
make a cameo and features DJ Khaled as
an informant similar to Lawrence Smith
does a fantastic job and the actor is
arguably one of the best of our
generation whether he's chewing up the
scenery pitching a dramatic
heart-wrenching moment are just being
the funniest guy in the film Smith is
pretty much up there with the best at
whatever he puts his hand to and here
he's no different the guy just oozes
charisma and it feels like he hasn't
aged since we last saw him in the role
in 2003 he provides the real heart of
the movie and for what was once a pretty
carefree and irresponsible character
Mike sure has a lot of growing up to do
in this movie we learned that before the
events of the first bad boys film Mike
was pulled from the police academy and
placed undercover in a
second drug cartel it's revealed that
during this mission the character fell
in love with the cartels leader's wife
named Isabel Mike took down the cartel
and Isabel was included with this and
she ended up going to jail with them
Mike genuinely loved her and he even
promised to run away with her
however Judy came before dishonor and he
ultimately had her arrested too as he
was well aware of how dangerous she was
we see this exemplified in the film with
Isabel becoming one of the big bads
she's pretty much the emperor palpatine
of the film controlling it all from the
shadows you can see how Mike was
captivated by her though and also I
realized that it was for the best not to
have a running around unchecked Isabel
went to jail but it turns out she was
pregnant with Mike's child and this is
revealed to be a mando if you've seen
Smith's last film Gemini man then you'll
know that it followed a similar sort of
plastic in that the characters
quote-unquote offspring was to a very
highly skilled assassin but here it
feels like it has a lot more heart to it
Armando is a great character and you can
see why they're planning on moving ahead
with him in a sequel which I'll talk
about later in the breakdown after he
helped her escape prison isabel has been
instructing a man down to take down all
of the people involved in the cartels
demise and it's up to Mike and Marcus to
catch him from the off bad boys for life
doesn't miss a step and it really is a
thrilling ride considering it's been
almost 20 years since bad boys - you
would think that this would feel a bit
dated and obsolete but it doesn't at all
I really went into the movie expecting
this to be a disaster even though I
loved the second film and thought the
first was okay I don't know though there
was just something about that trailer
that seemed pretty met to me I'm happy
to say though that I completely
misjudged the film and it's really
really good the movie perfectly balances
humor action and drama and this feels
like a restarts the franchise on the
right footing and then kicks a field
goal with it Mike and Marcus really feel
like their lives are at stake here and
whilst the other movies had their
tongues placed firmly in their cheeks
here it appears they could go down at
any second that's no easy task and the
script is helped massively by its
supporting cast made up of Mike's ex
Ritter who is the lead on a group name
which stands for advanced Miami Metro
operations in the end Mike Marcus in um
I'll go to Mexico City in order to
confront Isabel where Mike argues where
they're about how she raised a mando
Isabel tries to escape in a helicopter
but Marcus manages to down it and he
incapacitates the character this causes
a place to start a place into the ending
and the big turn of one of the main
villains Mike confronts a mando to
convince him that he's his father and
now he initially doesn't believe it
Isabel confirms it much to his surprise
isabel tries to kill Mike but shoots
Armando instead and she's taken out by
Rita with a fire raging at the location
it looks like it's over for our heroes
but our mando actually risks his life to
save them it's a big move for him as the
character almost dies himself they
managed to make it out and then mike
tells a man know that he will have to
pay for his crimes Mike will be there
for him after this Rita is named the new
police captain and Mike and Marcus are
put in charge of ammo they finally got
that happy ending that they all wanted
and in the end it turns out they were
bad boys for life
[Music]
but that's your end explain there though
this closes out the main part of the
movie that doesn't mean it's over and
the film actually sets up a sequel that
we know is now being fast-tracked by
Sony before we get into that though I
just want to let you know we're giving
away a free copy of dr. sleep to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with the chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on bad boys for life
in the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
February in the cell be shipped out from
then to ever get to the prize it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
anyway the mid-credits scene shows Mike
visiting Armando in jail the latter
seems to have come to terms with his
sentence and he actually seems to repent
for all of the bad things that he's done
in his life he's ready to pay his debt
to society
however mike has actually come to him
with a proposition though we don't know
exactly what it is I think it's safe to
assume that this will help to shorten
his sentence and it may involve the two
working together in order to get him out
of jail faster than a chance card in
monopoly it looks like Mike's son will
be getting a Redemption our next time
and no it is possible that he could just
be providing Intel from his cell because
yeah let's face it
why would the Miami PD want him out in
the world I actually think that the two
will team up together on a mission but
death what about all those policemen he
killed look shut up this is bad boys for
life the guy's been a bad boy since he
was born in prison and I do think that
the two will be working together to put
the kid back on the right track this
scene clearly sets up a follow-up film
and we might be seeing a sequel sooner
than the agonizing 17-year wait between
this film and the last one The Hollywood
Reporter recently broke the news that
crisp remnar a writer on bad boys for
life is currently panning the script for
a fourth movie Sony really had
difficulties getting the sequel off the
ground and moved through several scripts
and directors but it now looks like they
have the foundations in place to build
upon this and we will be seeing a follow
up to bad grandpa I mean bad boys for
life very very soon as for the film
itself I had a hell of a lot of fun with
it and this is definitely my favorite
out of the trilogy I never thought that
we would get to this point but I'm so
glad that we did as the movie is a
really
right January's are normally terrible
for the a trickle releases but this
underwater the gentlemen and in 1917
yeah that there's been some brilliant
entries that are pretty much made the
month better than a lot of last year
summer I'm really glad that Sony took
the time with this because I'm sure they
could have got whoever to write and
direct the movie and dropped it in 2005
or something they waited though till
everything was right and all of the
pieces were in place here for a great
film and it definitely doesn't
disappoint bad boys for life is a
brilliant ride that brings everything to
the table and seems to exceed in all of
the elements that it tries to add out
this would be a late Oscar contender but
what's here is a blast and that's why I
get an 8 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts and bad boys for life and what
you want to see in a sequel comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our
breakdown of our favorite movie of the
month 1917 which is gonna be linked at
the end we go over everything you need
to know about the movie so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you can support the
show by subscribing to us and patreon
and if you want to come chat to us after
the video then make sure you join our
discord server and description below or
follow us on twitter at definition
whitey that's the best way to keep up to
date with everything we do at heavy
spoilers and hopefully we see it over
there very very soon this is the channel
for people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]